this at this workshop I always have a
fond place in my heart for Berkeley so
and just a little bit of about my own
background I now teach at a law school
but I also in addition to actually
having my law degree from from here from
from Berkeley my PhD in computer science
is also from here so I've got a mixed
background here and so I love being able
to talk about these kinds of concepts in
this in this way that blends both the
computer science and the law and so I'm
going to talk a little bit about how we
might think about the ways in which the
law does or does not or either is not
capable of really quantifying this
notion of privacy or formalizing it in
some mathematical or or computer science
sort of way so we might start by
okay I haven't plugged anything yet yeah
that's right
so we might start by taking the example
of HIPAA the health privacy law here
which provides that a covered entity or
business associate may not use or
disclose protected health information
except as permitted or required by the
law and so there's this concept then of
using or disclosing protected health
information right and so that's a legal
requirement not to disclose protected
health information so the question then
becomes whether or not that legal
requirement is form Eliza belong
now the one thing that the first thing
that I want to notice about this is that
this legal requirement is expressed as
many legal requirements are I'm in the
form of a prohibition rights a
prohibition on disclosing protected
health information and so in many
instances what we're really trying to do
is to formalize not necessarily privacy
as a concept generally but a privacy
violation what we want to know is under
what circumstances will this legal
requirement be violated and so will be
what we want to be able to specify is
the the set of constraints or the sort
of mathematical situation that would
create a privacy violation right that's
such that that a when this thing occurs
a privacy violation has occurred that is
to say this particularly has been
violated now this of course then
requires some exploration of what counts
as protected health information as you
just heard in the previous talk
HIPAA is the one then that goes on to
specify that protected health
information is individually identifiable
health information and then it just
defines it somewhat circularly as
information that identifies the
individual or for which there's a
reasonable basis to believe the
information can be used to identify the
individual if of course goes a bit
further by also then creating the safe
harbor this provision that allows you to
escape liability by removing these 18
identifiers x' together with this
requirement that there be no actual
knowledge the information can be
identified I mean so if you think about
that what this is basically doing is to
create a carve-out to what counts as a
privacy violation right so what counts
as a privacy violation is disclosing
something but if you disclose things
that don't
these identifiers xan that automatically
counts not as a privacy violation under
the law other laws however are let's say
one side in the other direction they
they specify things which do count as
disclosing personal information without
necessarily specifying what counts as
not disclosing personal information
right
so the gdpr in particular applies to the
processing of personal data which it
then goes on to define as again one who
can be identified directly or indirectly
but then it further describes a list of
various things which are defined to in
fact be personal data obvious things
perhaps things like name and and
identification numbers but perhaps some
less obvious things like location data
online identifier z'
and the like and so what this does is to
create a positive list of things which
will definitively trigger the law
without necessarily providing a list of
things or a list of ways by which you
can definitively fall outside of the law
right the way that the HIPAA law did for
an example of a similar kind of system
within the United States you can look at
the Children's Online Privacy Protection
Act which again applies to the
collection of personal information from
a child and then personal information is
defined with this long list that's
perhaps a little bit hard to see because
it is so long again a list of different
kinds of things which are definitively
personal information under the statute
but a non exhaustive list because the
fundamental definition itself is that
personal information simply means
individually identifiable information
including these things but not not
limited to the things in the list right
so like the European law here this
provides a firm ative list of things
which fall within the category without
necessarily providing means of falling
outside of the category all right so
then how does one then go about thinking
about how one how one could formalize a
notion of which things fall in or
outside of this category of identifiable
information or again more precisely fall
in or outside of the category of a
privacy violation of disclosing personal
information disclosing personally
identifiable information right for a
long time of course that we have this
view the relatively narrow view
that what counts is being able to
determine the identity of an individual
record in the database right just then
what leads to the notion of Canada MIDI
and and this as the method of protecting
privacy right again notice this is the
method of protecting privacy because the
definition of a privacy violation here
is that you will be able to determine
the name associated with a particular
record right so if you take that as the
definition of a privacy violation that
in fact can demand he works perfectly
well alright so the next thing that I'll
notice about this is that if you think
that's the wrong results it's not for
any kind of true technical reason right
it's not that you can point to a
technical basis for describing to me
that cannon emitted unquote work because
you first had to determine what cat what
counts as working and that requires you
to make a translation between what the
law requires not disclosing personal
information and what your definition of
working yes you define working to be
that you do not disclose information in
such a way that you can determine the
name associated with a particular record
then canon de MIDI does just fine right
and so what what the objection then is
to Canon ibbity is presumably not that
that like doesn't satisfy some formal
definition of privacy but it doesn't
satisfy the formal definition of privacy
that we want and so that then requires
us determine well which formal
definitions of privacy do we want
presumably that is going to be a
question of plausibility what matters is
whether or not the definition you did
you decide you'd want to adopt the
formalization you would decide you want
to adopt of any kind of legal or policy
requirement is in fact plausible or not
right that's what we're looking for
we're looking for is a plausible account
of what the law requires and then that
is the thing that we can use to try to
determine whether or not we can actually
satisfy that using technical tools now
what makes what makes the underlying
definition for can dippity potentially
implausible but i don't think i need to
go through that with this particular
audience right but there's at least a
couple of different ways in which this
does not protect against certain kinds
of
problems that we might plausibly think
of as being included within the ambit of
what should count as a privacy violation
right one of which is of course
sensitive attribute disclosure so in
this 2-2 anonymous list two of the you
know relevant entries here have exactly
the same sensitive information
associated with an and so then the
result would be that that attribute is
disclosed even though individual the
individual record cannot be identified
and then of course we have the Netflix
prize example of the problem of size
knowledge or said differently the
problem of trying to determine what
counts as the knowledge within the the
scope of what the adversary will will
have access to and so of course can
limit is also quite sensitive to that
and to whatever kinds of assumptions you
might make about the background
knowledge of your adversary a different
way of thinking about the Netflix
problem in the way that I've previously
written about is this idea that it
depends on whether or not the adversary
should be modeled as one who's sort of a
completely unknown third party or
whether or not the relevant adversaries
include people with special knowledge
that might otherwise give them the
ability to make attacks that would not
be available to a broader to a broader
set of adversaries so then if we don't
like the underlying notion of privacy
that we might get out of out of cannon
or the one that can Dimity actually
satisfies how can we think about whether
or not we could develop again another
another different kind of account of
privacy that would be more plausible but
which at the same time is formal right
so we want something that's both more
plausible and formal something that that
is amenable to some notions of of
technical guarantees okay I mean so try
to think about the extent to which we
can or cannot do that I'm gonna divert
for a moment away from strict questions
about privacy and the like to think to
give you two contrasting examples of
where the law has been willing to
formalize and willing to quantify in
particular I mean another in which
mostly the law has not
so first when we think about a place
where the law has been willing to
quantify think about something of like
the loss of chance doctrine so what is
this let me describe this a little bit
so this is a class of problems in which
what happens is a doctor for example
fails to diagnose a patient and as a
result of the patient develops a disease
and the patient ultimately in this you
know in this particular case for example
dies so the question is is the doctor
ultimately responsible for the patient's
death the problem is is that diagnosing
a disease is only the first step in
actually being able to treat a disease
right many times when you successfully
diagnose a disease nevertheless the
treatment is unsuccessful and the
patient may die anyway and so the loss
of chance doctrine was was meant to deal
with this problem because see that so
the theory goes if that's the case it
could be that you could say that even
though the doctor you know failed to
diagnose this disease and perhaps was
indeed quite at fault for failing to do
so let's take that as an assumption
right the doctor should have figured
this out when the doctor did not the
patient may have in some sense suffered
no damage as a result in the sense that
the end result may indeed have been the
same either way
because if indeed the patient would have
died under either circumstance right the
treatment would have been unsuccessful
then in fact the doctors negligence
makes no difference and the patient
should not in that sense be able to
recover damages from the from the doctor
as a result but what's often the case is
it's not that it makes no difference but
it makes a kind of probabilistic
difference right what really ends up
happening is that the doctors failure to
diagnose means that the chance of
survival of the patient has gone down
right and so then the question is
whether or not the patient can be
compensated for that loss of a chance
the loss of the chance to have recovered
that the patient otherwise might not
have had the traditional rule was no you
couldn't recover for this loss of a
chance you had to show either
probabilistically that the patient was
likely to have survived otherwise and
then you could recover or if you
couldn't show that then you wouldn't
at all but what courts increasingly have
have come to is this notion well no we
really can quantify that risk or
quantify the loss right quantify the
additional risk as it were that the
doctor ended up imposing or the the the
additional loss that the doctor ended up
imposing I mean having quantified that
risk we can compensate for it okay and
so that's one one way in which the
courts have been willing to quantify
something right take this somewhat
amorphous concept of the responsibility
of a doctor and this in this in this in
these kinds of circumstances I'm going
to actually quantify them and compensate
accordingly I'll try to I want to turn
for the moment away from what we mostly
be describing of the HIPAA Privacy Rule
look at the HIPAA Security Rule so the
privacy the the the law that covers
medical privacy also has various
requirements with respect to the
security of such health information in
particular electronic health information
and so it requires that these kinds of
covered entities to among other things
ensure the confidentiality integrity and
availability of the electronic protected
health information or anything that the
business associates and the like right
but what do you mean by insure right we
don't literally mean insurance as in the
sense of like an insurance company but
we don't mean insure in the sense of you
know make absolutely sure that this will
that this will happen right make
absolutely sure that confidentiality
integrity and availability will be
maintained right such a thing is
impossible alright so what's really
required what's really required is that
they reasonably and appropriately
implement standards and specifications
in order to satisfy their requirements
so they have to have not perfect
security we know that doesn't exist that
would be crazy thing to require instead
they have to have reasonable security
that's a reasonable security well so
then the question comes to could we have
a formal model for reasonable security
right now I'm sure many of you are
starting to think down the road of I
love you know we could write you can
imagine all sorts of formal models for
reasonable security well would they be
plausible would be would they in fact be
the ones that we want to have right
would they be the ones that would
correspond to what the you know people
who pass these laws of policymakers are
like what they meant to do in the law
itself and I think the answer that is
mostly no and I think you get that by
looking at what what approach that the
law makers actually wanted companies to
take in in deciding whether or not a
given requirements would be reasonable
or not it's convincing better convincing
no I just mean look you know do you have
an account that we can agree upon as a
social matter and so in that sense I'm
I'm specifically pointing out an
extremely non technical question right I
just mean can we all agree as a matter
of just you know democratic systems and
governance and the rest that this is in
fact the right thing to do that's what I
mean by plausible or convincing or
something of the sort
all right and so I guess what I'm
pointing out right is that is that if
you want to distinguish the the model
that underlies Canon Emmitt II from the
model that underlies differential
privacy right it's got to be on the
basis of simply convincing people that
one of them is better than the other
and-and-and I mean convincing people not
in the sense of a formal theoretical
proof of that fact but rather in the
ways in which we just set law and policy
generally what's tough to be plausible I
assume when people was fun it was turned
out to be not so plausible nowadays I
mean okay I mean so yes and no right so
so what you what but what you're really
describing is that is that people may be
convinced for reasons that you think are
faulty right I mean in other words
convinced based upon faulty assumptions
about the future or about this the the
state of the you know the the state of
the technology itself well that's true
too
so I guess I I think that's absolutely
the case and so you are absolutely right
that this notion of plausibility or
convincing us or whatever is temporally
and indeterminate
differently or scrambling or maybe are
making the same thing under a different
name a plausibility which are again I'm
not sure okay let me just let me just
proceed further and then and then when
we get to the end let me let me see if
let me see if I can we'll come back to
this concept as well all right so in
this particular content in in this
particular context what I'm describing
here is again this notion of what will
count as reasonable security right
reasonable security itself is a bit
fleshed out in the regulatory rule here
which says that when you're determining
whether something is reasonable you need
to consider these various factors it's a
bunch of things that we need to take
account of to try to determine what
would count as a reasonable security or
not including the size complexity
capabilities of the covered entity their
technical infrastructure and the like
the costs of the security measures the
probability and criticality of the
potential risks to the information now I
want to notice that some of these things
are relatively straightforwardly
quantifiable things like costs and
indeed something like probability as
well right even though this is perhaps a
harder thing to quantify it is still
nevertheless something that is
potentially quite quantifiable on the
other hand criticality not so much
because here what we're being asked to
do is to determine something about the
nature of the risks themselves right not
so much about their likelihood of
occurring or even somehow their
relationship at some kind of technical
level but our notion about how much we
care about the risk right if if this
risk were to come to pass how much
should we care about that actually
happening now even here we could imagine
a form of this that would basically say
well look by criticality we mean
literally the dollars and cents losses
that would result if this if this risk
were to come to pass but mostly this
these kinds of concepts have not been
interpreted that way generally in the
law and there's been a lot of resistance
both in the security and particularly in
the privacy realm to trying to reduce
all such questions to simply a matter of
dollars and cents I think that however
plausible you might think that might be
out there I just used the word again in
the security sense I think that it would
be quite problematic to then
to model privacy purely in terms of its
economic consequences right and so so if
we don't want to do that what we're left
with then is the is the need to actually
evaluate criticality here and evaluate
in the way that I think is going to be
inherently non-technical in a way that
will require us to make some judgments
about how much we care about certain
kinds of things occurring even apart
from the question of the likelihood of
them actually occurring I mean I think
that's embedded in the way in which this
approach is generally described and I
think and which of the in which many of
the laws regarding computer security are
actually described and I think that
that's a let's put it this way an
account of what these kinds of security
laws would require that would be broadly
shared by those who are who are you know
working on laws of this sort right by
the law and policy types who pass these
laws who implement these laws who are
enforcing these laws and so what I what
I'm noticing here is this contrast
between on the one hand the laws
willingness to quantify certain kinds of
things but unwillingness to quantify
others right
and the way I would describe this as is
this notion of quantifying risk on the
one hand versus quantifying values on
the other right we can quantify risk and
we may even be able to count risks of a
certain kind but we I think are not
going to be willing to quantify values
nor even to try to count them up let's
say to count up the number of sorts of
things in order to be able to establish
there their relative social importance
okay so the question is whether it you
know which category does privacy sort of
fall into right is privacy the kind of
thing that looks more like loss of
chance looks like more like a matter of
just sort of computing a quantity that
then we can accept as a matter of law
and even if not literally computing a
quantity right defining a quantity
defining a pure mathematical concept
that will encapsulate our notion of what
it is we mean to require by these
particular privacy laws right where is
it
and I would argue I think this is the
the answer more like the security
situation that when we ask for
the protection of personal information
we are in some sense asking for
something that looks a little bit like
asking for our reasonable security that
we are asking for certain kinds of
things to occur in a way that our that
is sort of conceptually reasonable
without necessarily that being able to
be fully formalized into a mathematical
concept the black one and the red one
and the black one just to the point fire
exactly and what you're saying is that
would be kind of necessity performance
because also the value the right
requirement is not going to be
sufficient and we would have to apart
from the technical examination of the
security measures also Luca Peaks with
it and only then the combination of the
two yeah absolutely I mean I think
that's right and I mean I think look if
you look at the real world of computer
security right it would be a weird thing
to some for me to just decide that the
real world of computer security involved
involved you know all non-technical
questions right there are plenty of
technical questions involved in trying
to determine the sufficiency of security
but the idea here is that it's not
exhausted by that and so I absolutely I
agree with you that that that both on
the security and the privacy side that
the technical tools have a really
important role to play in trying to you
know as you describe it achieve that the
black language right what but that but
nevertheless that doesn't exhaust the
high that the top-level concept of what
it is that the law requires and so the
ultimate requirement of the law will
require
that portion and the values portion yes
I want to make sure that you not or
understand where you say that the values
portion is not informed by so what if I
reason about a bit of privacy
say this is how I understand the values
important then it allows me to do
community but I understand as a
technical matter can anemone allows XYZ
attacks so I should sort of conclude
that my my conception of the values was
maybe not you know but I guess what I
mean is so okay so then it can limine
allows XYZ attacks and then the question
and then the question is whether or not
those XYZ attacks whether you care about
them agree whether the values are
through captured by some approximation
to those can be a yes absolutely yes yes
yes
right so I'm separating the question of
whether or not the the you know the
identify well let's let's let's take a
different one whether whether attribute
disclosure quarter could not in fact be
protected against through Kay anonymity
right cannot right that's a purely
technical question from the question of
whether or not if sensitive attribute
disclosure occurs whether or not I
should care about that under this
particular law okay and so those are the
two separate questions that I'm just
just describing but you you in some
sense need to answer both of those
questions in order to be able to be in
order to be able to fully understand the
relationship between the legal
requirement and and the technical tools
so with respect to differential privacy
in particular you know one way to think
about the the concept that underlies
differential privacy here you know
through the fundamental definition is
this idea that then a privacy violation
right is an example essentially of a
pair of neighboring data sets and a
particular outcome such that essentially
you know the inequality goes in the
other direction right I mean that's what
you're looking for when you're when
you're when you're looking for
essentially a failure of something to be
to be differentially private right
and so the extent to which one defines
that as the underlying concept for what
counts as not disclosing personal
information then differential privacy is
the answer to that question right so you
could you could in that sense derive a
kind of underlying formal concept that
corresponds to differential privacy but
what I'm trying to point out here is
this the possibility that that some
examples of neighboring datasets and
outcomes right are are more socially
significant than others or at least
that's the potential right in other
words when lawyers and regulators and
the like are you know conceptualizing
these things in the first place they are
thinking about it in a world in which
not every D 1 D 2 and s are
indistinguishable from every other D 1 D
2 and s okay and so that's going to then
create a different perspective on how to
think about these sort of the you know
the underlying concepts here yeah that
will make it difficult I think to have a
fully formal notion of what the legal
requirement ultimately is going to be
and one-dimension Without Really
acknowledging that the risks are going
to be accrued by some while the utility
of benefits or others security it's like
the risk of a breach or something yeah
okay so so just to be clear I when I'm
describing values I'm still talking
entirely on the privacy side of the
equation and not the utility side and
when I'm describing risk I mean in some
sense having already decided the
question risk of what which is the
crucial question that needs to be asked
right like so so I'm assuming already
that I have some idea of what I'm what
kind of risk I'm measuring and then when
I say value I mean what's the what's the
problem that would occur if that risk
comes to pass right and when I and and
in defining that notion of risk you can
define it lots of ways it's extremely
unlikely that you define it as like risk
to freedom of speech or some such thing
right in other words I mean the risk
that these particular individuals have
this particular information about them
disclosed or this particular thing
happened to them or the like and so in
that sense it does incorporate a notion
of who is who is ultimately the one to
whom the harm is the falls and not
simply some abstract notion of harm
you know divorced from some question of
of who it falls what observe that
absence of differential privacy is not
the differential necessary and different
for privacy violation okay fantasy
assumes that's the red mass function key
he is defined is falsified but it may
exist in someone else's head in which
case you cannot produce a counter
example to the partial privacy they
exist I'm not sure I follow what so so
you can defer privacy is opposed to
state the sense that the for a fragment
function key is satisfies on the
properties yeah but the violation of
differential privacy may happen in
multiple different places
what is that this randomized function
key may not be defined in the sense that
it includes is the decision making
certain inferences for example I guess
I'm not trying to argue about when you
can or cannot construct a differentially
private system right I'm trying to say
what would it mean for a system that has
been designed to to ensure Canon emiti
for example to not be a differentially
private system right so in some sense I
I guess I I have in mind already some
kind of real-world implementation of
something right and the question is
whether or not that real-world
implementation of something in fact
violates some law or not right who's the
person and it's much harder to make this
argument
sure I followed that was it was there
help on this side I thought I saw it no
okay yeah yeah okay let me just you know
I'll take it just a couple more
questions in a minute but let me just
note that partially when we've been
focusing on differential privacy we've
particularly been focusing I think on a
realm of risks and values that are
particularly salient in the context of
datasets that are publicly disclosed
right and I think that's in part why I
actually think that the census example
is one example where you know this seems
like a primary use case for that for
this sort of system because I think in
the context in which you are in fact
going to have you know fully disclose
this kind of information you end up
having a much harder time being able to
reason about other sorts of consequences
and the like all right but I don't think
that same thing is necessarily true if
the disclosure is much more limited Nora
I think is the same thing necessarily
true if the if the activity in question
is not a disclosure at all and one thing
I want to notice is that if you go about
redefining every notion of personal
information in terms that are in you
know more related to differential
privacy rather than other kinds you know
other sorts of notions that that same
definition of personal information is
going to apply across the board in all
the different laws right because this
law in particular does not distinguish
at least not at this level between a
disclosure to the public and disclosure
to the single individual right any kind
of disclosure that is not otherwise
permitted by the various sorts of
exceptions falls under this prohibition
and so there's nothing on the face of
just the phrase disclosing protected
health information that allows you to
distinguish between public and
non-public disclosures when in fact
perhaps we may in fact want to have such
a distinction when we try to determine
the appropriateness of that disclosure
or the sense in which that disclosure
really is a disclosure of protected
health information
similarly everything that I said about
disclosure applies here equally to use
right notice it's use or disclosure and
if you start thinking about what it
would even mean to
the system that ensured differential
privacy with respect to uses of the data
and not just disclosures of the data I
think that it that too would be much
more limiting than we would normally
expect such a law to to be and I think
the same thing is true here when we look
at the GD P R which applies not just to
the disclosure of personal trainer but
to any kind of processing of personal
data extremely broadly defined under
this particular law and then similarly
here with respect to capo which is
actually not about really about
disclosure at all but about the the
collection of personal information in
the first place so despite this idea
that you know the same concept of
personal information a pose of in many
different places in the law I think it's
actually used differently in different
places in the law and I think the result
then is that we shouldn't necessarily
expect that a single definition let
alone a single technical definition will
suffice across the different places in
which the concept of personal
information appears in the law alright
so I'll leave that then with these three
principles that when we are modeling
legal requirements we're oftenly
modeling privacy violations rather than
privacy itself back to this notion that
when we are determining whether or not
the model is a good model it will be a
quest a social question rather than a
technical question in determining
whether or not the model is good and
finally distinguishing between
attempting to model risk and modeling
the underlying social values with that
I've happy to help you take any further
questions
we have time for questions and I think
it has to do with that little point
about probability so
in agreement right I agree so I don't
you think we disagree about this this is
my guess it just could be a question of
exposition really like they're measuring
a value and a quantity which which I I
just can't make sense and I'm wondering
I mean I think that's right
look I mean at some level depends on the
extent to which you when you compare
privacy and utility you think you're
doing that the entirely quantitatively
or not right so I do think I mean but
but even if that's non-quantifiable
there nevertheless is a real trade-off
between the two so I mean I think that
part of it still definitely needs to be
explored in all the ways that that
various speakers have have described
it's just that it's you won't be able to
do it in a purely quantitative format
so stick it seems to me that both things
like differential privacy as well as
others on fairness awareness but try to
say okay we can actually create a way to
look at the probability right through
moving these sorts of dials but actually
outsource the question not of how much
you care about the value but appellant
care about specific signs up harms to
those values you're kind of going back
and forth anew you ended up here
modeling privacy violations and opted
against the law is about saying they
want to limit certain kinds of harms
right to some underlying value but then
you're talking about modeling values and
I just wanted to unpack that a little
bit because I I think that some of the
ways in which the formalization I think
actually helps us to same thing you a
risk versus harm and then externalize
the question of Lakeville given the
value that may be armed how do we want
to think about our tolerance
understanding how much do we want to
move this dial that's gonna control the
probability yeah except for the fact
that it but the problem here is is this
idea that it's treating every everything
that doesn't satisfy this definition is
indistinguishable from every other thing
that doesn't satisfy this definition
right
and specific I'm just thinking at some
level of abstraction it's useful you
might be able to do that but I'm
skeptical and that's what I mean by
about the difficulty of quantifying
quantifying values that in other words
once you start to try to formalize the
notion of which forms of of
non-compliance with this inequality like
how they compare to each other or some
such thing I think I think that becomes
difficult to impossible to do I mean
itself doesn't suggest that you should
treat all harms to write all potential
loss of privacy in this way seyton well
I suppose except for the fact that that
then if our benchmark is going to be
compliance with this definition right
then the effect will be to say that if
you fall outside of this definition that
that that will be some kind of violation
of the law right I mean so and so so
when that I mean I mean again it depends
on which direction you think you're
going right if the direction you're
going is to suggest that differential
privacy should allow you to satisfy a
legal requirement I think that's
absolutely right right if the direction
you're going is the legal requirement
should be specified in such a form that
effectively differential privacy is the
only known method of satisfying that
requirement that I'm much more skeptical
about I mean I've stated a very strong
version of it right but I guess what I'm
noting is the that's the that's the
potential flipside of trying to
formalize the underlying legal concept
right so that's anybody look I could I'm
hoping to get one more thought but yeah
so I was wondering do you have an
example of something that you would
consider a successful sort of a formal
formulation of a okay if I understand
what what you just said you're saying it
would it's very perhaps too conservative
or too broad brush to require a
definition like this and I kind of agree
although I think they're different
reasons but I'm curious if you have an
appositive example of something that you
think is a well liked of the examples
you gave is there one that you felt did
a good job of sort of formulating a
requirement that that could then be
interpreted by regulators or courts or
whatever means when you say a thing that
would do a good job
I wasn't sure like what's the thing you
mean I don't want to take too much time
I don't want to put a requirement like
this Ian's a statue yeah what should we
and do you have examples that you think
are sort of successful at capturing you
know what is needed at the level
appropriate safer stature yeah so my
argument is we should seek well we've
got and that essentially this concept of
personal information is in fact
ambiguous but the ambiguity is
inevitable that's my claim I think the
distinction here is protecting the
private you you know fundamental right
for private information which is the
fact that the gdpr is doing I think
you're mixing up concepts here so we're
talking this is about protecting the
confidentiality right I met
in an agreement with these respondents
that given me their data and I promising
to protect their confidentiality and
this is a good example but GTR for
example is a great statute which is
about protective my allowing my
protection of my private data which is
it's a privacy law it has nothing to do
with protecting confidentiality so there
seems to be a mixed mixture I didn't
understand what you're saying but the
problem then is how do I know which data
is your data because in the GDP I forgot
the best thing that happened to GDP our
other side of getting these emails from
all these companies saying do you want
me to still continue to get sending you
junk mail yeah if you do then click on
the button yeah that was the best thing
that came out of the GDP our but that
was about my fundamental right to not
have my privacy no the Europeans the
Europeans have a totally different
motion of this and the Americans I agree
but the problem is that the problem for
both the Europeans and for the routes
relevant point in American law is that
you still need to define what's within
scope and so you may have an absolute
notion that because it's your data you
should have full control over it a
notion we don't have in the United
States and they do have in Europe but
then you still have to decide what
counts is your data and the whole point
of this analysis is to try to determine
you know what counts is your data I'm an
agreement with the Census Bureau to fill
out my census form because they provided
me with the confidentiality pledge that
they won't reveal my individual
information so that seems to be a
different concept I'm happy to keep
discussing more with anyone who wants to
follow up some more
I don't think I satisfy any of the
existing questions Digital
[Applause]